alright fam you had a break let's see
how we do this time yeah it's here folks
Doctor Who is back which means I get to
review the things as they air again nice
to be doing that it's been a little whoa
it has been uh well about a year so here
we go spy fall series 12 first episode
more Jodie Whittaker more of the TARDIS
VAM team Chris Chibnall back again I've
got spoilers I need to talk about but I
will save those if you've seen the
episode you know the big one but let's
start at the beginning and let's avoid
spoilers for as long as I possibly can
overall impressions I liked it I liked
it pretty well I don't want to over I
unlike as as I'm thinking about it and
this is one of the things that's kind of
tough about doing the reviews as they
air is I really have to go with my first
impressions and I don't have the time to
like sit and Mull it over the way that I
do like say with the rewatch is
sometimes when I do the overdue Doctor
Who review I shoot the real wife review
right after I watch it other times I
take a day and think about what I do
what I can't really do that here not if
I want to get this out in any kind of
timely manner but right now coming off
it I quite enjoyed it but I don't want
to be prisoner with moment based off
what happens in the last minute or so
which was very cool but that spoilery
and we'll get to it so overall it just
feels a little tighter and a little bit
more focused it had a clearer purpose
and intent in terms of an
narrative atone and most other things
that I can think of that then I've
usually seen from a Chibnall script so
the optimist in me looking at not every
episode of series 11 but the ones that
he wrote in series 11 looking back the
optimist in me said okay
Heath he did what he thought would work
last time but I I kind of got the
feeling he wasn't he was treating it the
way he probably treated most work as a
contract he got hired he'll write a hill
Bay he'll be fine but I think even even
people like series 11 don't single out
the Chibnall scripts as being the good
ones probably the best one he did was
the woman who fell to earth but I don't
know really anyone who's I said is the
best one of series 11 so I think he
might have had a little bit of wake up
but like okay let's let's knuckle down
and really put some more effort into
this now
I haven't really gauged reactions so I
don't know if this has gone over well so
far but it's working for me first of all
right off that just with the title the
vibe we get the espionage field the
James Bond not quite spoof but
definitely dipping into that end of
things which is a vibe that Doctor Who
is a show hasn't really done anything
with since God since Pertwee which very
huff and had a James Bond feel so that
was kind of cool just to see back in
general and there's kind of a neat thing
that I don't recall doctor who ever
really broaching the idea of treating an
alien sci-fi story like a spy story and
or having you know spies as we know them
like mi6 being headed up by Stephen Fry
who does nice work
you know encountering alien stuff like
because in the process of spying trying
to keep an eye on things around the
planet it makes sense that they would
come across this sort of thing
it's kind of funny that that hasn't
really happened yet I mean yes granted
in the universe there are dedicated
organizations for that like unit which
apparently they're really sticking to
the idea that unit is gone it doesn't
exist anymore there was like a one-off
line before about that they basically
made a joke out of it I guess they're
actually sticking to their guns on that
which not entire I feel about it but if
that's the way they're gonna go
the idea of an agency that is not
equipped and doesn't have the experience
dealing with this kind of thing running
into and going oh crap can we find the
doctor let's find the doctor that's cool
I like that I dig that there is there's
an element to the 13th doctor that I'm
prepared to just sort of swallow and
it's been consistent enough that I'm
prepared to accept it as like not a
fluke of a couple of one-off things but
as an aspect of her character that I
have mixed feelings about and that is
how plugged in she is with current era
Earth technology and it's not like I
feel like she should be befuddled by it
but it's one of those things that makes
the doctor feel a little less alien a
little too human which is can be a
sticking point for me sometimes so you
know the fact that she texts the you
know the fact that she recognizes you
know all these all these things that are
of this time and he doesn't and she
doesn't sorry I didn't mean to do the he
but I'm doing this at the same time as
I'm doing overdue Doctor Who reviews we
got to get my head in the right space
but she you know she picks up right away
what all this stuff is and part of that
just annoys me because the doctor being
super plugged in to earth you know tech
and not like big important tech but just
like what's going on and like on the
ground level tech of the time or picking
up pop-culture references of now like
I've never liked like one of the lines I
one of the jokes I really didn't care
for in the Christmas invasion was it was
the Lion King joke with the doctor
quoting liking somebody just doesn't sit
right with that with me but what I will
acknowledge is there is a really a
reason that that can't be the case
especially given that the doctor has
pretty much always known
kind of stuff about other planets if
only because he has to be able to
explain it to to the companion so there
wasn't a reason that she wouldn't know
the this sort of stuff um and even there
I did he I did he cuz I was thinking
back to earlier doctors like it's gonna
flip back and forth just roll with me
but she there isn't a reason why she
wouldn't know the stuff about Earth when
when off world the doctors frequently
explaining this sort of stuff to the
companion so like it makes sense and
it's consistent enough now that like
this is just kind of her thing you know
earlier doctors have been you know the
the Tenth Doctor yelled at at Martha and
Jack accusing them of blogging and the
eleventh Doctor just this sneer when he
said the word Twitter at one point but
those aren't reasons that the thirteenth
doctor can't be a little bit more oh
this is fun about it and I mean we've
had consistency of egg just with her
reaction to the KaBlam man so like it's
fine it's not an inconsistency and I
guess it's a chosen character trait I
just don't love it that said like the
overall vibe of this thing just sort of
plunking the doctor and the companions
down into this sort of story I thought
was quite fun and I feel like I've
gotten more attached with most of these
characters at this point I don't know
how much of that is just I've I've now
spent enough time with them that I I
will still say like looking back at
series 11 they really didn't establish
all these characters the doctor
especially as well as I really needed
them to especially early on but at this
point I've had a series and a special
with them so I've I get them now so
coming in it it feels more like Oh back
with these folks again okay and I'm not
spending my time trying to figure them
out
and because series 11 didn't do an
exceptionally good job of getting me to
understand these characters that was a
detriment to my viewing on series 11
which isn't really case in series 12
because
we know all of them going in so that
that kind that helps it's it's like the
opposite of the familiarity breeds
contempt in this case the familiarity
gives me the space to just relax and
take in what what I'm seeing which that
works that's cool
yeah I think I'm gonna have to start
getting into slightly more spoilery
stuff here's the other thing that I'll
say before I get into spoilers which is
that I do enjoy this episode and I think
it's step in the right direction
I'm going to not suddenly declare this
means everything will be great because
and this isn't just a Chibnall thing but
in modern era Doctor Who two-parters are
hard and more often than not part one is
better than part two there's only a
handful of instances that I can think of
where that didn't end up being the case
so I I will be curious to see how the
landing gets stuck on this but I got to
start talking about the more meat of
what goes on over the course of this
which means spoilers that's your warning
okay so here we go well let's talk about
the big one the Masters back I was not
expecting that on multiple levels I was
not expecting like there to be any
significant twist with the character of
Oh like and I was enjoying him and that
was neat and that was cool
and what really like hats up and I'm not
even wearing my head for this video but
hats off to this move because that's the
kind of twist that dr. who usually has
been leaving to until the two-part
finale this is the kind of thing I would
have expected in part one of a two-part
finale story so to drop this in episode
1 of the new series nice nice so that
but that at the same time that does give
me
couple of concerns and it's not
necessarily that I think oh well this
will go bad but like if you're if you
are new to the channel I tend to zero in
on the things that like okay they got to
be careful because that might go wrong
that's how my brain works it's just what
happens so I'm nervous about the master
saying to her everything you know is a
lie those kinds of big statements coming
from villains always make me nervous
because they usually tend to be part of
these sort of I am the I I'm the
architect of all your pain and I've like
controlled everything going on and and
like it overreaches I just hate that
plot I hate that trope so I'm really
hoping it's not a first step into going
into that I'll be very curious to see
how often the master pops up over this
series because part of me wants is they
like have him be we're not every episode
necessarily but to treat him basically a
bit like the big bads from Buffy where
he's in the background and like it pops
up a couple times and then you know
again at the end what I don't want them
to do is to just not have him show up
again until the finale that would bother
me that what that would annoy me a
little bit um but I part of the reason I
think that structure will be nice to see
is because it would be a series arc
that wouldn't be just bringing back the
mystery box and that's another reason
I'm kind of scared of the everything you
know is a lie line like that sounds like
the plenty of a mystery box arc and I
don't want those back so I'm a little
bit nervous there but I thought he gave
a great performance and the reveal was
great I told you to find the spy master
the spy master I'm just sitting there
going oh nice and I really like that
they did a master that like I don't know
what I would have imagined for Jodie's
master it's not this so it just
surprised me on every level and I'm
really gonna be curious to see what they
what they do with that and that dynamic
I I'm like we only get a little bit of
what he's gonna be like and not you know
once he does the turn at the end so
again it has the potential for them to
overplay it now that we know who he is
but as far as initial planty of it goes
I'm yeah I'm on board
hi I want to see where that goes I want
to see how this this goes down I also
and also like it makes sense that the
master is pairing up with another race
that's up to something he's done that
before I love that they brought back the
frigate tissue compressor that is one of
the cheesiest things from classic era
Doctor Who when they brought it back
complete with the Titan II he's gonna do
the match box yeah one of those things
so campy I never thought it would come
back I kind of love it I kind of love
that it did that's just really cool um I
loved the doctor and it succeed oh
because like I mean I'm a sucker for
women tuxedos anyway but I love that you
see you're going up to the housing you
realize the coattails are a little too
long and the pants are a little dryer
and she's still got the boot she's still
not it's not quite right it's not
actually proper fashion I'm like that
perfect love that the action scenes
while they weren't highlights for me you
know the car and then the motorcycles
they didn't drag it down too much either
they didn't dwell on those for too long
which is good because I've said before I
don't have a problem with action scenes
in Doctor Who but that's not what I'm
here for so as long as they don't eat up
to time too much time or feel like the
show was trying to make them the thing
I'm most excited for cuz that's never
gonna be the case then I'm fine with
them and that's basically here I'm fine
with them the other companions were good
they were solid they were fine you know
just just in terms of jumping I like
that I like that there was a thing
between Ryan and Yaz where he's
pestering he as for her sister's number
because I'm hoping there's a strong
indication that they won't romantically
pair off those two cuz I don't want that
nonsense
either so that's cool and Graham still
like him he's just sweet
she's just sweet and endearing this is a
really solid start I think it's it's got
a really fun vibe but it just feels
tighter it feels a little bit more
polished and I mean that mainly in the
writing because visual presentation is
good but visual presentation was very
good in series 11 that was for all the
things that I complained about series 11
it looked very good and this looks good
and like the visual approach to whatever
the heck these aliens are very cool a
unique interesting I'm mm-hmm and
actually I think tying them into the
master kind of covers what in my head
was a little bit not necessarily a plot
hole but of but an annoyance which is
you know why did these interdimensional
beings or you know things from beyond
the veil of time and space always end up
coming to earth every friggin time why
well in this case if it's the master he
would have brought them here just to
mess with the doctor so the inclusion of
him would this like that works I'm down
and but but getting back to what I was
saying like it looks good but I wasn't
worried about the looks I was worried
about the scripts and the script is a
little bit tighter a little bit shinier
a little bit more polished
I felt like most of especially Chibnall
scripts for series 11 needed at least
one more revision if not two or three
and this feels like that's that's about
as polished as this concept and these
characters are gonna be for this story
cool here we go
which is not to call it a perfect script
that's not what I mean but I mean when
if you've ever written any or tried to
write anything yourself you know you
write out the basics here's what happens
this this this and this and then you go
back to you or finding you polishing you
go oh wait I don't need this because
this accomplishes that same thing or
there's something missing here bring in
that you know you polish it and you
tighten it up a number of his scripts
specially in series 11 felt like they
needed just a little bit more tightening
and this doesn't have that feel and that
is encouraging like I said I'm gonna be
a little bit nervous waiting for the
next episode because second half of two
parters are tough even the good ones
usually it's the first part that's
better
like even some of my favorite two
parters you know the the impossible plan
of the satan bit love them both first
ones better you know world enough in
time and the doctor falls both great
first ones better so i think that's the
case more often than not cuz setups I'm
not gonna say our easy but payoffs are
harder so we'll see I'm just happy to be
watching this again though it's nice
feels good
Doctor Who spy fall you seen it what do
you think about it whatever your
thoughts are stop Oman down on the
comments and let's talk about it all the
usual stuff you know the YouTube things
the likes and subscribes and share this
with your friends and like most youtube
creators I also have a patreon if you
feel like supporting me helping me cover
my bills and maybe even grow this into
something bigger and better than it
already is
all that stuff down in the description
you know the links to that various other
stuff but you don't have to click on it
either cuz the end of the day you're the
council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]